what's happening there reject nation we
are going to watch today from new
rockstar spider-man no way home ending
battle cameos explained you know eric
vos is going to be combing through every
little shape and silhouette to explain
which character this might have been i'm
i've been waiting for this one he said
he's gonna be doing this like a couple
weeks ago actually so i'm glad it's
finally here where where where i get the
shirt you ask oh my god you love his
shirt so much it's from epic hero shop
that's right that is from new rockstars
themselves they did not send it to me i
bought it with my own money that's right
pay top dollar for it i think it's
limited time so if you guys want to get
one yourselves go over to there today
appreciate everything you guys put
together let's see what's in store
[Music]
welcome back to new rockstars i'm eric
boss and spiderman no way home burst the
marvel multiverse wide open but you know
what not wide enough because despite
green goblin blowing up that machina
dickadama da da domina dabadabados two
crappy purple reality riffs in the sky
nearly inviting hundreds of awesome
multi-dimensional cameos into the mcu
doctor strange and peter parker just had
to slam the door in all of their faces
don't they know that um we have an open
door policy in this house of em at least
to everyone not named ralph boner
because we already have one
i have seen no way home five times in
imax and still trying
however i could actually make out quite
a few of these several more than i
initially spotted in my big old easter
egg breakdown wait wait a minute 10
million views holy spirit
let's break down the new cameos i found
and what that tells us about the plans
to introduce these characters in future
films the most prominent among all of
these is a figure holding a spear with
thick shoulders this is craven the
spiderman villain that the no way home
screenwriter is actually initially cited
as a villain of interest for this third
film when they're writing it but in the
months since cast by sony as mco pietro
maximov actor aaron taylor johnson for
an upcoming solo film most likely gonna
be based on the amazing craven's last
hunt comic i think we can expect craven
to take place in that sony
villain-dominated side universe of venom
and morbius morbius a movie that was
just delayed from january to april
perhaps to give them time to include a
cameo by andrew garfield spider-man
since that morbius trailer did show the
garfield continuity oscorp tower and
graffiti of spider-man as a murderer and
andrew garfield peter mentioned falling
into a violent church exactly exactly
and morbius will also feature the mcu
michael keaton vulture well maybe that
was a sloppy spill from this reality
into that one when all those rifts were
happening or maybe just another
confusing example of some variants
looking like the same actors across
different realities as we saw with jk
sims j jonah jameson yeah i definitely
think that's just a variant it just
seems like so likely that this would be
in the andrew garfield universe even in
the andrew garfield universe i think
it's a spider-man one or two one one of
those where you do see like a file name
list of venom and morbius when he's like
going through some files so it just
seems to reason that and i imagine that
all they did was just go yeah
we could use michael keaton because it's
sodium spider-man he's just a variant
version let's just have it be that i
wonder if he's craving the hunter
version if it's like a sneak peek if it
is like a sneak peek of what with the
actual design of what they're planning
to go for with aaron taylor johnson
specifically or they're gonna go all
jared leto version of it and just make
him a pretty handsome aaron taylor
johnson no they want to gauge everyone's
responses all the fans backlash to this
so that they can change the look and
make it perfect on this one light
silhouette because he does look big and
imposing and his silhouette like damn i
hope entertailer johnson bulks up to
match this frame if you look right to
craven's right there is a figure on all
fours with the curved tail this is oh
[ __ ]
it didn't being played by michael i
think i might have thought that was
vulture at the time would have a more
tech heavy mechanized suit the way
michael keaton's vulture did in that
movie yeah i mean i remember in the toy
leagues they have one of scorpion and
i've been waiting for michael mandel to
come back i feel like they just stopped
giving his [ __ ] when scorpion is one of
his greatest road gallery villains come
on bring him back michael mano's an
amazing actor watch better call saul and
know exactly why you want him in here
this looks more like the comic accurate
scorpion who often goes on all fours to
scorpion's right is a more slender
figure that actually matches the shape
of black cat oh [ __ ] another title sony
for quite some time damn i'm just trying
to make that out
by felicity
2014 andrew garfield amazing spider-man
2. but if you go back over to the left
of craven is a smaller figure with four
extended arms coming out from the back
who aggressively jerks its head to the
side on first glance this kind of looks
like carnage who does extend tentacles
from his symbiote anatomy but it also
kind of looks a bit like the spider-man
doppelganger he created during the
infinity gauntlet storyline who goes on
to join carnage intrigue and maximum
carnage but ultimately i think this is
most likely the superior spider-man
incarnation in which otto octavius swaps
his consciousness into spider-man's body
and operates a suit with iron
spider-esque arms it's actually a pretty
great storyline that takes place in the
616 continuity that'd be crazy if they
decided to include that version now that
we've been getting like multiverse
spider-man in in a movie of our heroes
it's only a matter of time before we
start really seeing like villainous
takes of spider-man i'm so excited that
would be like i'm not talking venom
incarnate talking like actual like this
is a spider-man but a villainous take on
that yeah how cool would that be man a
man spider movie can finally happen but
the second shot of the rift shows a
silhouette that you probably caught a
bulky figure turning a head with a
prominent horn this is of course rhino
and actually maybe a more comic accurate
version of the character than the paul
giamatti alexey sistovich that andrew
garfield peter mentioned fighting back
in that 2014 film but then to the right
of the rhino is a harder to pin down
slightly
rounded head that many have described as
mysterio's fishbowl helmet but seeing
still images doesn't really do these
justice you really have to see them in
motion and to me it's really the way
this figure steps so timidly toward the
rift with some adolescent awkwardness
really i think this is either gwen stacy
spider-gwen oh [ __ ]
have slender builds and rounded heads
shaped by their masks considering the
other silhouettes placed prominently
toward the front are all big names that
sony has in active development i think
elektro and andrew garfield peter's
discussion about a black spider-man
somewhere out there points to this being
a miles morales from another universe
let's see if across the spider verse
acknowledges any of this i'm waiting for
that moment i mean they've got the you
know universe hopper thing and this guy
like i can't fathom many reasons and not
to bleed it into this world this could
be a live action universe where miles is
already spider-man or it could just be
the same miles from spider-man into the
spider versus my right or my right or
right there are some other silhouettes
in the periphery that are a lot harder
to define and we probably won't know for
sure until no way home comes out on 4k
but you can begin to discern some shapes
for example in the shot of the rhino to
the left there is a character walking
leftward across the frame who has a
shape protruding from his head looking a
bit like loki's curved horn headpiece
sure while he's an mcu property not a
sony one this whole sequence was brought
about by doctor strange's multiverse
magic and i would not be surprised if
the movie's artists mixed some mcu
characters along with their sony ones
and that loki series introduced us to
countless loki variants at least one of
whom must have known that peter parker
is spider-man and that walking figure
passes another character that strikes a
familiar pose while aiming a weapon
almost looks like a bow and arrow we
could be looking at a variant of hawkeye
or kate bishop or task master or
bullseye but i don't know striking that
pose it also almost looks like an iron
man variant extending his repulsor arm
i was most interested to spot is visible
only when the peters first look up at
that craven rift the brightest figure on
the far left of that lineup which looks
like a slender seated figure with a
number madame
interesting hairdo coming out from the
top of it
this could be madam
a psychic mutant who sits at the center
of the web of life's destiny that
bridges all the spider verses together
as we expand further and further into a
live-action spider-verse madame webb
would be the figure you would see
peering out from an interdimensional
rift like this and they did talk about
how they have a madame web movie in
development
like ages ago when we're getting more
announcements about like spider-man like
it feels like any idea that they toss
out in a writer's room or a board
meeting it just somehow leaks and i
think that uh madame webb was definitely
one of the top contenders and as we are
expanding the spider verse madame webb
if we're going through comics would be a
very essential piece to all that would
be cool if it is a tease to her though
yeah get helen mirren in the mcu let's
do this yeah it's the only one he would
cast right and with that little
mysterious moment of peter spider-sense
able to bypass the magic of doctor
strange as peter was in his astral form
i think that's a little indicator that
all peters could share a cosmic arachno
frequency that stems from madame webb
and this silhouette's position in the
front of the line leads me to suspect
this could be her and if those rumors
speculating that sam raimi directing
doctor strange to the multiverse of
madness could be a way we get tobey
maguire peter parker to come back for
that multiverse
i hope coming along with him through
that multiverse is his
you can support new rockstars yeah make
doctor strange's spiderman movie yeah
me on instagram and twitter
boss follow me rockstar subscribe to
rockstars for more announcements of
everything marvel thank you for watching
bye
sweet dick that was great video that was
fantastic that was really exciting and
it's too much exciting imagine eric just
in an imax theater going wait okay
that's the best i can do in the moment
sure none of that was cam none of it was
looked up none of this at all
ethically guys subscribe to new
rockstars they haven't done so already
they are the bomb
subscribe to the real rejects click that
notification bell hey let's do a p
everett pixelmight baker you'd be
perfect to be one of the cameos at the
end of spider-man no way home your name
is pixel my baker what you would be
is the pixels in there would be you but
you'd be shaped like dylan baker the
lizard from spiderman sam raimi universe
you would be a hodgepodge variant right
there we would go that's everett
pixelmite dylan baker the lizard you
would have a tail in everything you sexy
son of a [ __ ] you'd also be the sexiest
silhouette
of them all man that's right flame on
your tail ass that's what we would be
doing i'm gonna put that out you sexy
sizzle everett thank you so much for
being part of our patreon page for such
a long time by this point man i mean
you've been around with us since like
2018 and we are in the new year hope to
keep you around even longer even if you
don't want to be here just like how the
villains didn't want to go over to this
universe you are stuck here love you